For years, Goldfish, a tasty subsidiary of the Carp Group, was a quiet company.
Goldfish's shares barely traded on the stock exchange and had no website.
Carp's chairman, Mr. Whale, never spoke to the media.
Their quiet blue sea ran red when a barracuda invaded the annual shareholder's meeting.
These insurgent shareholders, had the media in a feeding frenzy,...
...and were intent on scaring the company into transparency and higher stock prices.
Suddenly, Goldfish executives had to answer uncomfortable questions.
Why was a Fish company investing so much money in the unrelated fields of moon exploration...
...and desert mining units of the parent firm?
Had the details of these fishy transactions been fully declared?
Were these investments to benefit Goldfish shareholders - or the Whale family empire?
If Goldfish's grilling sounds familiar, it should.
The Korea Corporate Governance Fund, is a domestic barracuda,...
...who is emulating other corporate activists like Carl Icahn...
...and the Dubai - based Sovereign Asset Management...
...-foreign investors who ripped their way into some of South Korea's meatiest corporate icons...
...by demanding greater accountability to shareholders,...
...but ultimately conducting what many saw as unfair greenmail raids on the companies.
The appearance of KCGF means that fat tasty companies will now have to swim fast...
...to fend off not only corporate raiders from outside...
...but also from inside South Korea by improving their management.
And this will be positive for both stock market shrimps and whales.